>> Tucker: GOOD EVENING AND
WELCOME TO "TUCKER CARLSON
TONIGHT."
DEMOCRATS HAVE BEEN TALKING
ABOUT IMPEACHMENT SINCE THE
VERY DAY THAT TRUMP WAS
INAUGURATED BUT UNTIL
RECENTLY NO ONE HERE IN
WASHINGTON TOOK THAT IDEA
VERY SERIOUSLY.
MAXINE WATERS WOULD RANT
ABOUT A TRIAL AND THEN
PILATES MOM IN SANTA MONICA
FANTASIZE ON TWITTER ABOUT
REMOVING TRUMP BY FORCE.
THE ADULTS IN THE PARTY,
NANCY PELOSI, FOR EXAMPLE,
THE SPEAKER IMPOSED
IMPEACHMENT ON THE GROUNDS
THAT IT WAS BAD POLITICS.
IT MIGHT BOOMERANG ON THEM.
THEN, IN WHAT SEEMED LIKE A
DAY, EVERYTHING CHANGED
COMPLETELY.
SUDDENLY WE HAD IMPEACHMENT
HEARINGS PLAYING OUT LIVE ON
TV.
NOBODY EXPLAINED WHY.
LOOKING BACK, WHAT EXACTLY
HAPPENED?
WELL, PART OF THE ANSWER IS
THAT DEMOCRATS WERE SIMPLY
RESPONDING TO THEIR OWN
CHEERLEADERS ON CABLE NEWS.
>> IF PRECEDENT MEANS
ANYTHING IN THE TRUMP ERA,
DONALD TRUMP WILL BE, MUST
BE IMPEACHED.
>> BUT IF THEY DON'T
IMPEACH, DEMOCRATS WILL
ADVOCATE A CLEAR
CONSTITUTIONAL CHANCE TO
HOLD THIS PRESIDENT FULLY
ACCOUNTABLE.
>> THE NATIONAL NIGHTMARE IS
UPON US.
THE BASIC RULES OF OUR
DEMOCRACY ARE UNDER ATTACK
FROM THE PRESIDENT.
WE BEGIN TONIGHT WITH A
SERIES OF ADMISSIONS BY THE
PRESIDENT THAT ALL BUT
ASSURES HIS IMPEACHMENT IN
THE HOUSE OF
REPRESENTATIVES.
>> I DON'T UNDERSTAND WHY
THE FACTS THAT IMPEACHMENT
IS POLARIZING MAKES THEM
JUST AS COWARDLY AS THE
REPUBLICANS.
>> ABSOLUTELY.
TO MY MIND, IT ALSO IS AN
ABBY OCCASION OF THEIR
CONSTITUTIONAL
RESPONSIBILITY.
>> WILL THERE BE ANY
CONSEQUENCES FOR THIS
PRESIDENT WHO IS CONTINUING
TO DEFY THE RULE OF LAW.
>> Tucker: THE RULE OF LAW.
HEAR THAT MR. AND
MRS. AMERICA.
IT'S A NATIONAL EMERGENCY.
IF THEY DON'T IMPEACH,
DEMOCRATS, LISTEN CAREFULLY,
DEMOCRATS, WILL ANT VOYEUR BE A
DEMOCRATS, WILL ANT VOYEUR AE A
DEMOCRATS, WILL ANT VOYEUR ABDA
DEMOCRATS, WILL ANT VOYEUR ABDIC
DEMOCRATS, WILL ANT VOYEUR ABDIT
DEMOCRATS, WILL ANT VOYEUR ABDI.
THAT'S THE HAIR HATS ON TV
MEN WHO WARE MAKEUP AND
YELLING AT THEIR ASSISTANTS
WERE TELLING DEMOCRATIC
LEADERS NIGHT AFTER NIGHT
AFTER NIGHT.
REMARKABLY, AND IT IS
REMARKABLE LOOKING BACK
DEMOCRATS BELIEVED THEM.
SO WHAT HAPPENED NEXT?
LET'S SEE, HAVE YOU READ THE
NEW VANITY FAIR?
I'M SORRY RHETORICAL
QUESTION.
NOBODY READS VANITY FAIR
ANYMORE.
IT LIKELY WON'T EXIST BY
THIS TIME NEXT YEAR.
BEFORE THE TITLE DISAPPEARS
FOREVER, CHECK OUT THIS
MONTH'S ISSUE.
THERE IS A FASCINATING PIECE
BY KEN STERN THAT ASSESSES
NEW POLLING ON IMPEACHMENT.
HERE'S THE HEADLINE.
AMONG INDEPENDENTS, THE ONLY
GROUP THAT MATTERS IN AN
ELECTION SUPPORT FOR
IMPEACHMENT, IMPEACHING
TRUMP HAS DROPPED BY 10
POINTS SINCE THE PROCESS
STARTED.
HOW TO EXPLAIN THIS.
IN POLITICAL TERMS, THIS IS
THE ANDREA DOREA A ROUTINE
CRUISE THAT SUDDENLY BECOMES
A DISASTER, A DEBACLE.
THEY SPENT TWO WEEKS TELLING
THAT YOU DONALD TRUMP WAS A
CRIMINAL.
AND BY THE END, NOR PEOPLE
SYMPATHIZED WITH DONALD
TRUMP.
HOW DID THAT HAPPEN?
TAKE A CLOSE LOOK AT THE
NUMBERS.
AND IT'S OBVIOUS HOW IT
HAPPENED.
INDEPENDENT VOTERS WERE
ASKED TO RANK 11 ISSUES IN
ORDER OF THEIR IMPORTANCE.
FIRST ON THE LIST WAS FISCAL
HEALTH.
74% OF INDEPENDENT VOTERS
SAID THAT THE BUDGET DEFICIT
WAS THEIR MAIN CONCERN.
72 PERCENT SAID HEALTHCARE
WAS THE MAIN CONCERN.
70 PERCENT SAID
INFRASTRUCTURE.
PRETTY CONVENTIONAL.
IMPEACHMENT, THAT CAME IN
DEAD LAST.
11 OUT OF 11.
ONLY 37% OF INDEPENDENTS
THOUGHT IT WAS A PRIORITY AT
ALL.
BY A MARGIN OF 3 TO 1, AND
THIS IS HILARIOUS,
INDEPENDENTS SAID THAT
IMPEACHMENT WAS MORE
IMPORTANT TO POLITICIANS AND
THE MEDIA THAN IT WAS TO
THEM.
THESE ARE NOT SUBTLE
NUMBERS.
HOW DID DEMOCRATS MISS THEM?
WELL, BECAUSE THEY ONLY TALK
TO EACH OTHER.
THIS IS WHAT HAPPENS WHEN
YOU LET JEFF ZUCKER RUN YOUR
POLITICAL PARTY.
YOU START TO IMAGINE THAT
CNN'S PRIME TIMELINEUP
SOMEHOW SPEAKS FOR AMERICA
RATHER THAN FOR A TINY
OUT-OF-TOUCH LITTLE PART OF
IT.
ZUCKER TELLS YOU THAT
IMPEACHMENT IS THE ONLY
MATTER THAT MATTERS.
HIS MUNICH AGREE WITH THEM.
COME FALL YOU LOSE THE
ELECTION.
FALL NONPOLITICIANS WHO SEEM
TO SEE THINGS THE MOST
CLEARLY.
HERE IS ANDREW YANG AFTER
LAST WEEK'S PRESIDENTIAL
DEBATE.
>> BUT, WHEN I TALK TO
VOTERS AROUND THE COUNTRY, I
HAVE TO SAY I GET VERY, VERY
FEW QUESTIONS ABOUT
IMPEACHMENT.
I KNOW THAT THERE ARE PEOPLE
WHO ARE VERY INTENT ON THE
IMPEACHMENT PROCEEDINGS DAY
TO DAY.
BUT THAT DOESN'T LINE UP
WITH WHAT I'M HEARING FROM
VOTERS HERE ON THE GROUND.
>> SO WOULD DEMOCRATS, YOU
BELIEVE, BE BETTER OFF
SIMPLY WRAPPING UP THIS
IMPEACHMENT PROCESS SOONER
RATHER THAN LATER?
>> I DO THINK THAT THE MORE
TIME THAT GOES ON THE LESS
TIME THE DEMOCRATS HAVE TO
PRESENT A POSITIVE VISION
FOR THE COUNTRY THAT WILL
GET PEOPLE EXCITED AND HELP
US WIN IN 2020.
>> Tucker: OUT IN SANTA
MONICA THE PILATES MOM
SAYING ANDREW YANG, DID HE
IMPEACHMENT?
IS HE A RACIST?
IS HE TELLING US THAT VOTERS
WANT POLITICIANS TO CARE
MORE ABOUT THEIR LIVES THAN
THEY WANT POLITICIANS TO
EXTRACT SYMBOLIC TELEVISED
REVENGE ON THEIR POLITICAL
ENEMIES?
[LAUGHTER]
IF YOU WATCH MSNBC IT'S HARD
TO BELIEVE THAT COULD BE
TRUE.
THAT'S WHAT THE YANG GUY IS
CLAIMING.
IN THE WAKE OF THOSE POLL
NUMBERS WE JUST READ, OTHER
DEMOCRATS APPEAR TO BE
CONSIDERING THE SAME THING.
EVEN ADAM SCHIFF MAY BE
COMING AROUND.
WATCH THIS.
>> DO YOU THINK PRESIDENT
TRUMP SHOULD BE IMPEACHED?
>> I WANT TO DISCUSS THIS
WITH MY CONSTITUENTS AND MY
COLLEAGUES BEFORE I MAKE A
FINAL JUDGMENT ON IT.
AND.
>> AND YOU'VE ALSO SAID THAT
WHAT YOU HAVE SEEN IS,
QUOTE, FAR MORE SERIOUS THAN
WHAT NIXON DID.
EXPLAIN TO ME HOW YOU HAVE
NOT COME TO THE CONCLUSION
THAT THE PRESIDENT SHOULD BE
IMPEACHED.
IT SOUNDS LIKE YOU THINK HE
SHOULD BE IMPEACHED.
>> I CERTAINLY THINK THAT
THE EVIDENCE THAT'S BEEN
PRODUCED OVERWHELMINGLY
SHOWS SERIOUS MISCONDUCT BY
THE PRESIDENT.
BUT I DO WANT TO HEAR MORE
FROM MY CONSTITUENTS AND I
WANT TO HEAR MORE FROM MY
COLLEAGUES.
THIS IS NOT A DECISION I
WILL BE IMAGINE ALONE.
>> Tucker: HE IS NOT GOING
TO MAKE THE DECISION ALONE.
JUST SO YOU GOT THE DECISION
CLEAR.
THE MAN IN CHARGE OF
IMPEACHMENT IN THE HOUSE,
THE MEMBER YOU JUST WATCHED
FOR TWO FULL WEEKS
SHEPHERDING THE IMPEACHMENT
HEARINGS.
THE GUY WHO CRIED ON
TELEVISION JUST THINKING HOW
MUCH DONALD TRUMP NEED TO BE
IMPEACHED RIGHT NOW, THAT
GUY ISN'T REALLY SURE IS HE
FOR IMPEACHMENT.
YOU KNOW, HE NEEDS TO TALK
TO HIS COLLEAGUES.
HE NEEDS TO HEAR MORE FROM
HIS CONSTITUENTS.
IT'S A LOT TO THINK ABOUT.
HE IS GOING TO PRAYERFULLY
CONSIDER IT OVER THE HOLIDAY
WEEKEND, JUST ALONE, JUST IN
SOME REFLECTION.
THAT'S ADAM SCHIFF'S